one of the most important things to
remember about this referendum is that
it's what's called an advisory
referendum which means it's non-binding
which means that the Prime Minister is
not under any obligation legal
obligation to act on it
now of course Parliament has said and
David Cameron has said that it will be
acted on but if you're looking at the
letter of the law
it can be overturned one thing that
could happen for example is that if we
if we saw snap elections and if in the
course of those elections who saw the
emergence of a political party that
actively went to the voters and said
because of the unexpected fallout from
from break that from the referendum we
are now giving you a choice yeah
seventeen point four million people
voted against it but you still have
millions and millions of people who also
voted to stay in the European Union
through this so and who now feel quite
angry and upset about it so there is a
huge constituency of people out there
who might be ready to vote for a party
that runs in a on a platform to overturn
the referendum so this could offer
interestingly a way back for the for the
Lib Dems if Scotland the elephant in the
room
I mean Nicola Sturgeon was very clear on
Friday about the risk of Scotland
leaving so on that level she has put her
cards on the table in Saturn and a
second independence referendum is very
possible but in terms of overturning
breaks it it could happen again it's one
of those things if you if you really dig
down into the into the into the
constitutionality of this yes Scotland
could make life difficult for break said
it could certainly hold it up but again
and politically this Nicola Sturgeon
really wants to be the person who stands
in the way of seven of the will of
seventeen point four million voters who
who voted to leave that does seem
unlikely